[Music]
on this Mother's Day weekend we have a
very special Saturday session last month
Carnegie Hall released the album hopes
and dreams the lullaby project 12
lullabies performed by some of the
biggest names in music including Fiona
Apple rosanne Cash and Rhiannon Giddens
but the songs were co-written by
amateurs expectant mothers with no
songwriting experience you'll hear two
of those amazing lullabies performed
here in studio 57 shortly
the first here's Michelle Miller in the
time spent waiting for a sonogram
appointment we expected parents did
something that blew their minds writing
their unborn baby a lullaby so far so
good we was like thinking like we can't
really write a song you know like the
experience is given to parents once a
week here at the Jacobi Medical Center
in the Bronx he'll listen to it as a
baby and he'll always remember that it's
both of us like what we feel and how we
thought about him before he was born
yeah you know like that's always gonna
be like a family thing their teachers
Carnegie Hall musicians Marika Hughes
and Deirdre Rodman struck begin the
process asking parents to compose a
letter to their child which is used for
the lyrics then they practice practice
practice in a matter of a few hours
they produce melodies for three moms in
a dad personalizing each to the parents
pitch passion do you speak any other
languages Arabic Arabic even the
language of their choice I have a secret
history as a composer of lullabies the
lullaby project is the baby of Carnegie
Hall's Thomas cabinets when I was a
young musician in New York and I had no
money I had a friend whose wife was
expecting they were going to have a
child and I decided since I didn't have
anything else to give them that I would
write a lullaby for the baby
I loved writing the lullaby I loved
being able to give it to them as a gift
[Music]
cabinets thought composing a lullaby
would be good for first-time parents
especially those insecure over being too
young or having to go it alone what can
you say to people in the greater
understanding of what this does and what
this means it's in the songs you can
hear it in the music that they create so
to me that's where the evidence is in
the last six and a half years his
project has produced more than 800
lullabies songwriting he says is a gift
of healing and connection it's expanded
to shelters and correctional facilities
[Music]
this year those songs turned into a
professionally produced album featuring
some of the biggest voices in music
Patti LuPone Dianne Reeves Catherine
zeta-jones how did you get folks to sign
on board well we were very lucky Joyce
DiDonato who is a big metropolitan opera
star heard about our work and came and
sang with us on a concert and she
invited a record producer he said I bet
I can persuade my friends and their
friends to come in and sing these
lullabies because they're amazing
they're beautiful and people should hear
them at first I thought what am I gonna
do one of the songs is peace it brings
me joy written at Jacobi Medical Center
five years ago by tamela's Fernandez for
her son Lavie I was just excited to have
a song that I could show him from when I
was carrying him and she's proud that
her words may one day helped to spark a
movement what would it mean if having a
lullaby was just part of the the birth
process we're hopeful that the partners
who come together with us will honestly
they'll help us create a kind of lullaby
movement because that would be amazing
[Music]